في تركيا وضمن الانتقادات المساره حول
كارثه انهيار المباني ما تزال مدينه ارزين
الصغيره قربا هاتاي تثير الكثير من الحيره
لماذا هذه المدينه التي يبلغ عدد سكانها
42 الف نسمه لم تسجل اي انهيارات للمباني
او اصابات رغم الماساه التي شهدتها ما
حولها من مدن السر كما يقول اوكي السائل
مازوجلو عمده المدينه هو الالتزام الصارم
بقوانين البناء وابلاغ النيابه عن
المخالفين ويشرح ان المباني لديه بين
طابقين واربعه مع مبنى واحد من سته طوابق
وانه رفض الضغوط للقبول بالاستثناءات وجاء
السادس من فبراير ليثبت وجهه نظر العمده
الشاب بعد ان منيت المدن من حوله بعشرات
الاف الوفيات بينما باتت عشرات الاف
المباني تحت قيد الهدم الاجباري المفارقه
ان العمده خسر الكثير من تاييد ناخبيه قبل
الزلزال بسبب صرامته في موضوع البناء
والان يتلقى الكثير من النقد بسبب حديثه
عن عدم وجود ضحايا في مدينته اذ غابت عنه
المساعدات الحكوميه بعد زلزال لم يعجب هذا
الامر البعض ممن طروا للمبيت في الخيام
خوفا من العوده لمنازلهم المتصدعه
ورسالتهم له عدم موتنا في الزلزال لا يعني
انه ليس لدينا احتياجات